assassin's creed is a 12 game series
featuring massive open worlds and tons
of hidden secrets with the recent
announcement of assassin's creed mirage
a game set to hearken back to the
structure and design of the first
assassin's creed i think it would be
best to take the series back to its
roots these are 10 things you didn't
know about the original assassin's creed
number 10 half horse half man half
terrifying the horse in the original
assassin's creed is a handy and
trustworthy steed to get you from city
to city i bet you didn't know that horse
was actually a man former ubisoft
developer charles randall revealed that
because technical limitations at the
time only allowed for bipedal characters
they had to stretch out the model of an
in-game npc and animated and rigged it
to move like a horse a similar
workaround was found for the character
of malik whose missing arm was actually
a tiny scrunch up little arm inside his
sleeve
number nine assassins roll out
when traversing through the cities of
damascus and acre there are sets of
window arrangements that form the shape
of the front of g1 optimus prime in
truck form
number eight the sacred texts npc
dialogue in aker has a civilian confused
as to which text he's quoting well the
bible does say god helps those who help
themselves
nah it doesn't actually
that's from one of these fables the
bible says quite the opposite in fact
many passages are being patient and
faithful and waiting for the lord to
decide if he wishes to assist
well i say we've waited long enough
[Music]
number seven assassins couch co-op
according to julian marcerone former
ubisoft technical director the original
assassin's creed experimented with
having local multiplayer according to an
article and interview on dual shockers
it states that in fact there was a bug
while he doesn't know when it was
patched at some point if a second
controller was plugged into the console
a second assassin would appear on screen
the team didn't even test for those
features as they thought they were
disabled and that's how the bug appeared
although there aren't any other details
on what multiplayer would have looked
like multiplayer features wouldn't be
featured in another assassin's creed
until assassin's creed brotherhood in
2012.
number six
side missions shmide missions although
modern-day assassin's creed games pack
in a lot of side content i mean i got
valhalla on launch day and i still
haven't cleared the map the original
assassin's creed didn't have any until
five days before release charles randall
detailed that the game was ready to ship
and had passed all levels of scrutiny
until the ceo's kid got his hands on it
the kid reported that the game was
boring and there was nothing to do
randall's lead came to him and proposed
the idea to put inside missions with the
stipulation that we have to put all
these side missions in the game in five
days and they have to be bug free
because the build is going to be burned
directly to disk and released to retail
randall described the next five days as
a blur the only notable bug that
remained in game from the frantic five
day stint is that one of the templars
you're supposed to assassinate falls
through the geometry and is unable to be
accessed causing you to restart your
game to get a full gamer score i think
randall puts it best though i know it's
a miracle that the game just didn't melt
your console
number five
the animus the fictional device that
allows desmond to travel into his
ancestors genetic memories is called the
animus this is a direct reference to
part of the collective unconscious
theory by psychoanalyst carl young young
described the animus as the unconscious
masculine side of a woman and the anima
as the unconscious feminine side of a
man each transcending the personal
psyche although not specific to just
assassin's creed 2007 a number of the
female characters throughout the greater
series have names relating to the stages
of anima development as detailed by
young eve maria auditorium de ferenza
and sophia sartor just to name a few
number four multilingual one of the many
real-life historical figures you run
into during your time in the holy land
is richard the first commonly known as
richard the lionheart during your
interaction all of his dialogue is
spoken with a french accent
oh yes
a great feather indeed
now our enemies will be that much
stronger in their convictions although
the king of england at the time richard
spent most of his life in the angevin
domains in france that would put him on
the modern day western side of the
country reinforced by his appointment as
duke of normandy
number three historical fiction when
creating the world of the first
assassin's creed the team at ubisoft
looked to real-life historical figures
as well as works of fiction surrounding
the time of the crusades to layer into
their storytelling the story of altair's
order was inspired by the life of hassan
isaba he is reputed as the founder of
the real life order of assassins known
as the azari ismali state or hashashin
and ruler of the mountain fortress known
as alamut in turn alamuts was used as
the title of a 1938 novel by vladimir
bartol the novel is set entirely at the
fortress of alamuts and follows a young
soldier joining the ranks interacting
with hassani sabah frequently throughout
the siege of alamut by the seledoc
empire the assassin's creed team at
ubisoft used many of the plot points in
the novel as story threads throughout
the tale of assassin's creed the novel
also creates the famous main principle
of the assassin's brotherhood in the
novel it is stated by hasani sabah as
nothing is absolute reality all is
permitted in the game the motto is
tweaked to nothing is true everything is
permitted altair's garb is also directly
pulled from the novel the timeline of
the game is not the same as the novel
however with altair and the members of
his sect of hashashan existing during
the third crusade in 1191 hassani sabah
died in 1124.
number two on eagle's wings eagle
imagery pops up again and again
throughout the series but especially in
the first assassin's creed when
designing the look of altair animator
kai nguyen used a bird of prey as the
design concept the original design had
altair in long flowing robes but because
of hardware limitations they created a
much sleeker feathered look for his
garments obvious eagle inclusions are
the eagle that flies away when you mount
a viewpoint in any of the major cities
eagle vision and the aviary screech when
performing a leap of faith but because
the assassin was not supposed to be the
main character in the original concept
of the game he didn't have a name when
the assassin roll became the main focus
of the story they gave him the name
altair which means the flying eagle in
arabic
number one
prince of persia assassin initial
development for assassin's creed started
in 2004 as a prince of persia game after
the successive sands of time ubisoft
tasked prince of persia director patrice
desolate to begin work on the next game
in the series for the very mysterious
seventh generation of consoles in order
to accomplish something that would live
up to the intense hype surrounding the
power of the ps3 and xbox 360 desolate
ditched the linear progression model of
the prince of persia levels and replaced
it with a vast open world set in the
holy land during the height of the
crusades along with the massive scope
the game added huge crowds and easy
parkour access to every level of the
three major cities for the most
immersion possible to put it in
perspective sands of time could only
allow for eight characters on screen at
any given time assassin's creed allowed
for 120 but after nearly two years of
development ubisoft was not ready to
give over the project to a new ip the
game had you play as an assassin
bodyguard of the prince and watch over
him through guided scenarios in which
you'd have to use your skills to save
him or get him out of other perilous
situations so basically the entire game
was one big escort mission
thankfully the prince character was
dropped and the assassin's creed evolved
into the game we know it as today
[Music]
assassin's creed defined what the open
world genre would look like for ubisoft
during the past three console
generations the series itself has gone
through some award-winning highs lows
that have made it a divisive series
throughout the gaming industry and a
reinvention that flipped the formula in
a fascinating way it's been enthralling
to go back to 2007 and see where the
series has come from along with the
thought and principle that went into its
world and story with the new entry in
the series assassin's creed mirage
freshly announced an emphasis on a back
to basics mentality from ubisoft will be
interesting to see how they execute it
within the framework of how different
assassin's creed looks and feels today
from its inception for more on
assassin's creed mirage make sure you
subscribe to gamespot check out our
rockstar editor jordan ramay's chat with
the art director of assassin's creed
mirage come find me on twitter at stewie
review and thanks for watching